well welcome back I'm a lover of red
meat but my next guest takes it to the
extreme Brian Johnson also known as the
liver king that's brought his
unconventional lifestyle to the
mainstream with millions of fans but is
his clean living all As It Seems
this is what the liver King is having
for dinner today I'm having liver with
breakfast lunch and dinner because liver
is King
[Music]
foreign
you know what somebody said that earlier
you might not know this I'm actually
wearing a muscle shirt
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm making this video to apologize
because I [ __ ] up
yes I've done steroids I am as sorry as
a man can be
well Brian Johnson aka the liver King
joins me now uh well thank you for
joining me uh Brian your nine ancestral
tenants which is what's made you so rich
and famous uh our sleep eat move Shield
connect cold Sun fight Bond pretty
laudable lineup of tenants to have in
life I would argue
um but you've got to add another one now
10 which is steroid drug abuse how much
do you think that has damaged your
reputation and your integrity
first of all I deserve what you just
said and I also want to say thank you
for giving me this opportunity to come
on here to talk about this my job is to
acknowledge how bad people are hurting
today I believe there's this path
forward a better life to live I call it
ancestral living thank you for giving me
the opportunity to talk about this how
much does it damage my Integrity a lot
you know but but what I want to say is
this is um
my Integrity my my brand
um I would say that this doesn't have
anything to do with the north store the
North Star the message is far bigger
than me right the message really is
people are hurting at record rates
there's a better life to live it can be
achieved through an ancestral living I
mean it's interesting I got a text
message today from a very very famous
television personality who is known for
his own Healthy Living
um he said to me that you screwed up
with the steroid stuff but your heart is
good
you got you're a lovely family man your
views on living an empowered life
through struggle Primal nutrition Sun
ice and Community are spot on so
notwithstanding the steroid Scandal he
thought that actually the tenants that
you stand for that you've been promoting
still stand the test of time so I guess
it's going to be interesting isn't it to
see what your fans make of this because
a lot of it is down to trust isn't it
you come bursting onto the scene you're
hugely popular you're making all this
money but it's based on the belief that
your diet which is obviously very
unusual I've got some of it here the Raw
Liver they're constantly eating that is
what turns you into the person we see on
our screen when in fact it's now turned
out to be largely driven by steroids
there's a trust issue there
I understand that and I hope that we
have the opportunity to eat some raw
liver together since since you have some
there
um
there's a trust issue here right and you
don't have to believe what I'm saying
but what you have to believe is that the
world is hurting at record rates that
these are the facts that 4 000 people a
day actually kill themselves that 80 000
people a day try to do it 85 percent of
the population they struggle with
self-esteem issues eighty percent of the
population struggles paycheck to
paycheck 70 or overweight half are obese
50 percent are on prescription medicine
forty percent however will get cancer
and 20 want to have kids and can't have
kids so what you got to believe is this
these are the facts so now how do we
lead a better life how do we get better
how do we start to overcome these issues
what I believe right and I've gone and
visited with modern day private culture
tribes in the Amazon and Africa and
Mongolia This Is How They Live these
nine ancestral tenants they don't have
material possessions they're kicking ass
in life you know so so what I'll tell
you is this I live this way before
social media I've eaten these things I
have liver I have some testicle right
here I have some bone marrow right here
um we ate this way my family I did this
before social we're going to continue to
do this on social after social we'll
continue to live this way I believe so
deeply in this that this is my why in
the world this is how much I get all
this and it's interesting to me look I
think a lot of what you say makes sense
and I'm sure it would benefit people the
problem people are going to have is how
much of you and your body has actually
come from this diet that you've been
promoting and this lifestyle and how
much of it has come from just taking
steroids because anyone can take
steroids and pump up so now there's a
sort of cloud over the like I said the
Integrity of your whole sales pitch
which is you can look like me if you do
this but actually all the time you were
taking steroids
sure um listen I mean it's impossible to
say how much right but I'll tell you
this um there's a new video today on
Tick Tock before steroids were ever
involved in my life right if you want to
know what's achievable how I did it
prior to any kind of enhancement
whatsoever go to tick tock check out the
video you'll see that um while I think
it's completely impossible to say what
percent right um I would say I've
achieved 90 of my physical growth of my
physical success without any kind of
PEDs whatsoever
but you also repeatedly in interviews
denied taking steroids so it wasn't just
a question of of cheating if you like
because that's clearly what steroids do
in this kind of scenario but it was also
a question of lying when you were
directly challenged about it and I just
that you obviously had you know I was
aware of you because of the sheer uh
huge presence you have online and my
sons knew about you and you know
everyone was sort of aware of what your
stick was but a lot of it was based
around a belief that what you were
saying was true
and you know how do you feel on a human
level to have to sit here now as
somebody who's been proven to be a drugs
cheat and a liar these are not things
anybody wants to be uh accused of being
let alone admittedly
no yeah listen I feel like a total piece
of crap you know I mean I know what I
did was wrong I lied about it I feel
like I've LED an entire generation down
part of the reason why I feel so
horrific about it is I know what it
feels like to be 10 11 12 13 14 15 with
zero self-worth completely embarrassed
and humiliated of the brain and body
that I have right and so when I connect
with these young people I know how they
feel right um I I feel like I betrayed a
whole generation of people you know and
so what I would say is I hope you
continue to engage with my content right
these nine ancestral tenants these are
the true north this will enable you to
live a better life but if you don't
engage with this content what you still
have to acknowledge is the true north is
people are hurting and hating and
suffering and struggling okay and do you
still believe that eating raw liver is
the is the real answer to to life
you should have some too I know I've got
some here and I'm gonna have some
Piers Morgan eats liver with the liver
King you know well it doesn't not it
doesn't taste too bad I'm not squeamish
about food I'll pretty well eat anything
raw or cooked it tastes okay I couldn't
imagine living on it three times a day
but I could probably have a go final
question and we're running out of time
are you ever going to take steroids
again
so I'm currently on them right now and I
have a plan to come completely off of
them I believe so deeply in this message
the nine ancestral tenants I know that I
can come off of them I know I can still
kick ass in life okay you won't see the
same guy in a couple of months but I've
got to leave you there good to have you
in the program I appreciate the honesty
finally thank you for joining me